[Laughter]
it's
uh you weren't prepared for that much
fat irish face were you
it's always a shark
all right here we go my guest tonight is
of course a comedian who's appeared in
numerous films including
get him to the greek and for getting
sarah marshall uh he has a podcast
entitled
under the skin and his new audible
original
revelation connecting with the sacred in
everyday life is available now
please welcome a man i hope will become
my personal guru
in life russell brand russell how are
you
ah well i feel very happy to see you
there in your new environment your new
location your largo are you trying to
summons up some ambience
yes yes i'm at the largo theater which a
theater that you've performed at many
times you're well known here
thank you i apologize for the mess and i
paid as best as i could for the cleaning
don't shine a blue light in that
dressing room
oh but you see you've you've come so far
that's the old russell the scamp the
sexual satyr the um
uh the spirit animal uh free i mean when
i first met you
uh doing doing the late night show in
new york city
i was told that you had arrived i never
met you before i came backstage
you were dressed all in leather and you
were you were prowling
you were a trapped jungle cat and i
remembered
the sensuality and creativity coming off
you the ferocity
uh you could not be tamed look at you
now
you are at peace you are
in touch with the universe around you
you appear to be sleeping
on a bed these are all things that can
only happen to a man who's finally found
his inner peace how did you do it
i tell you what it is conan perhaps all
evolution is the result
of the relationship between appetites
and environment look at mythology it's
always on about appetite look at native
american
mythology the crow the hair the horny
little trickster
eventually these appetites take you to a
place where you need to change the
appetites can only take you so far
your carnal brutal need for fame and
power as represented by that priapic
phallic guitar behind you even now red
and throbbing like your haircut
it can only take you so far i mean there
aren't many people
in the world who have penis replacement
hairdos
solely you you're like a male medusa
with a single pry epic
monolith a unicorn a singular horn
a living lucky charm al conan yes i'm
telling you
first of all russell you're right i've
i've skated as far as i can go
on this absurd pastry that i call hair
you of course see it as a phallic symbol
but then again you see everything
as a phallic symbol a guitar suddenly
becomes a
throbbing male member what is an
innocent
childish hairstyle to you becomes a
threatening
male orgasmic
penis i'll say
does not we just have to call it what it
is but
i do look up to you so much russell
you're very uh
honestly do you really mean that i don't
know i mentioned all those things i
don't mean to interrupt you particularly
not when you seemed on the brink of
paying me a compliment a shocking thing
in itself remember i'm english and uh
a compliment might bring me to tears
with stuart still
racks with grief in this country what
i'm saying is like that
there is an ulterior realm the material
world the world of things and symbols
is a referent to a deeper reality now
people think this is
you know hocus pocus uh cockamamie new
age
tomfoolery but the fact is that the
senses are limited
our capacity for knowledge is limited
but the potential for information
is limitless like our cosmos i believe
there are techniques and methods that we
can use
ways of directing our appetites and
drives that can bring us to a point
of awakening that's what i believe i'm
not claiming to be there yet
i'm still a strange person i'm still
wearing these
strange strange socks and feeling these
strange strange feelings
but on a pathway conan i'm on a pathway
with you
you and i your pal clammy hand in my
brown
hairy mitt the two of us
walking towards the light of the lord
well okay well let's talk about your
life now you're a very domesticated
fellow now
um you uh you live uh with your lovely
uh wife you have uh
children and you have lots of animals is
that correct it's like
a farm where there's no end product you
know
like it's like agriculture where at the
end of it you don't have
i don't know wheat or milk or cheese
you just have feces strewn on every
surface
all anyone does in this house is
defecate and create stools from the
kittens to the children
even the adults in fact but according to
protocols we use a latrine
that's the british way that's how we've
held together the empire
all these merry years and that's why you
will still pay taxes without
representation
so like uh yeah it's like it's like it's
like
like it's like the product is just
excretia conan like
but um yeah i mean i can show you cute
animals i can
leave my um john and yo car yo john and
yoko style bed and
take you on a wander through my humble
home and show you some of the kittens
and stuff
i'm i'm happy to do whatever you want to
do russell you are my guru
you are uh you are my light i look to
you because
i think you could be my salvation i do
i i that is a heavy burden for anyone to
bear
the idea of cleansing your soul you'd
need a hell of a lot of bleach and some
thick rubber gloves but i'm up for the
job
[Laughter]
let me ask you something um you uh
i know that in your country it's a big
deal right now that prince philip has
passed away
and i believe you performed for prince
philip once didn't you
yes i did actually perform i did the
royal variety performance
i don't know who was booking that event
and what they were anticipating
i do remember making some jokes that
were you know
saucy as you might imagine and
subsequently mining
that territory in a way that scarcely
seems appropriate
while it's curious here because some
people are obviously deeply in mourning
but also the bbc received the highest
number of complaints
ever because the coverage was so
expansive of the funeral
and the sort of general mourning around
prince philip
it's interesting isn't it to consider
what the future of the monarchy
might be in the light of the
you know the senior generation
presumably
reaching their mortal conclusions look
for me conan
you've got to be kind of cautious like
this because i even though this is
primarily broadcast in america and very
few people watch it there
if on the internet
if on the internet i was just saying if
there's something insensitive
right about a recently deceased royal i
know what it's like to be
dragged into that quagmire so i will say
like it's
an interesting and transitional time for
all of us and the death of any person is
a
a very very sad event but kind of it's
um i suppose it's revealing
it's revealing that this is increasingly
i suppose a place a world of cultural
division
where the likes of you and i conan can
surely bring about union
in our own ways though for caucasians we
may be at the opposite end
of the melatonin scale we share more
surely london divides us i think we are
very similar
yes you have uh beautiful
uh olive skin dark piercing eyes
um thank you you are as i said before
a um an untamed
panther uh i am very uh
pale um many people think that i'm ill
and um i have very little uh
to recommend me uh in the sensual realm
but i still think that you and i um are
very much alike
we're both questing comedians looking
for truth don't you think
i see you as a powerful lord of mischief
and misrule a maturely minded man
able to skip between subject subjects
and
access realms that are it takes a lot to
like what is comedy really
other than the acknowledgement that this
whole thing is a divine play the whole
thing is silly
that we take ourselves seriously we take
the world seriously and
sooner or later someone has to point out
that this whole thing is absolute
nonsense
it's madness it's madness and that's why
you
uh are being interviewed on what's still
a nationally broadcast television show
in the american empire
the richest country most powerful
country in the world um
and you are lying in bed uh wearing what
appears to be a free robe that you got
in first class on an airplane
so
enough i i've made a personal vow
never to re-wear any of those
first-class pajamas
i leave them there on the plane i wear
once
and i move along it's the only area of
my promiscuity that i've allowed to
remain
is with first-class pajamas
elsewhere i am monogamous and stoic
sometimes almost celibate man living in
honor and integrity
here yes may i may wield a crystal wand
what is that yes what is why do you have
a crystal wine
well who doesn't have a crystal wand
about their person in this day and age
these are challenging times
you leave your house without a crystal
wand you're in jeopardy my man
okay okay
let me i only use it for magic it's a
gift actually from the great danny
harrison
oh son of a good great former beatle
george harrison wonderful man
yes i love i love danny he's a good man
a very good man
he's a beautiful person do you think
that there's a visual subtext
to this that's all i would say all i'm
going to say is i think candle maybe
um i see nothing sexual about it at all
that's right it's just a crystal tip
wand of magic and love and if you can
think of another context for that then
it's your problem
exactly then you've got a dirty dirty
mind
i want to talk to you if i may russell
about
audible original revelation connecting
with the sacred
uh in everyday life uh i wondered if
and when you were going to bring that up
because as you know i'm obligated to
promote that not that i consider it to
be any great chore
i was willing to take the money i
enjoyed writing the audible original i
was happy to
read it out in the booth and as it turns
out everything i said i believed in
is meant to be an exploration of the
sacred but you're the professional
you're the man behind the desk in front
of an electric
organ of some description please
guide me through this topic as you've
done so many times
still yet without portraying any sign of
world weariness
um i my soul died a long time ago
russell and uh it actually my soul left
my body on camera
in 2002. um you can actually see the
episode where it leaves
um i believe i was talking to david
hasselhoff and it just left
uh has never returned but i want to talk
to you about this because
i think it's a great mix of the serious
and the silly
i think you you you take this uh to
heart this
search for truth one of the things that
you wanted to do
pre-pandemic to help promote
this audible original was to go out into
the world and try things
experience things you wanted to take
ayahuasca is that true
i'm in recovery from drugs and alcohol
one day at a time
for over 18 years i think it has become
clear in the world
conan now that materialism
and post-enlightenment rationalism is no
longer
providing us with the solutions we need
to everyday life this is why there is so
much division
take this time of pandemic where the
stated objective is to somehow return to
normal
it's a normal in inverted commerce that
many many people were deeply
dissatisfied with
the fissures and fractures in both of
our nations are
evidence of how unhappy people have been
for a long time and while superficially
we may be squabbling about
borders boundaries walls or
even serious subjects such as race or
gender or sex
i think that all of this is in fact a
reference to a deeper spiritual
malays like many people i think uh
cultures that have retained a connection
to mystery sometimes through shamanism
may have answers that we ourselves need
to access at this time
the problem is i've burned all my drug
bridges even if they're lovely cozy drug
bridges
taking you know psilocybin or stuff
taken in a jungle in a complex way with
a shaman
i can't do it right i'd like you to do
it
and to vicariously experience the giddy
thrills of hallucigen's
what you're proposing is that because
you are in recovery and congratulations
on that that's
that's uh a great achievement because
you're in recovery
what you'd like to do is have me take
ayahuasca
and you observe me and see how i react
and that will give you the necessary
information you need is that right
all i need is for you to wear a simple
humble body glove
for us to be neurologically connected
through a series of sticky patches
so that i see what you see and i feel
what you feel
it's the body glove great a request to
make of you
i mean like the psychedelic world is not
the only way to experience revelation
revelation and epiphany are encountered
and experienced everywhere
we were all looking for something but i
think it's the body glove which is
selling me on it most for us listen to
me
russell were you to see me in a very
tight form-fitting body glove
body glove you would experience quite a
revelation i promise you
hello old friend
[Laughter]
you know i um i would do that for you i
i'm very fond of you uh i'm a big fan of
yours and i would happily
take this uh this
i would take an ayahuasca i would i
would do it
i don't even know what it is i'm very
straight studies have revealed
conan but psilocybin the active
psychedelic agreement in
ingredients excuse me in magic mushrooms
is as effective
in treating depression as the best
pharmaceutical depression drugs that
there are
i'm fascinated in this i mean as i say
for me as a person in recovery it's a
sort of it's uh
like it's something that i have to be
extremely cautious about but
you as a man who sacrificed his soul
sold tonight ryder decades ago
you've got very little to lose
you work you are right that i can only
go
i can only go up from here from where i
am you're looking at
a husk of a man a dried-out husk a man
who gave everything he had to american
television for close to
30 years and um how have i been repaid
uh to be mocked by a man lying in bed
uh on on a british isle that uh
that uh you know our people fled uh
hundreds of years ago
um this is my fate now this is what i
must be subjected to
is you you laughing at me in bed
it's other realms that hold the solution
for
you and i conan the material world the
late night world
it's given you all it has to offer it
has nothing else to give you it can only
take
from you now it can only continue to
suck at your grey
presumably noodle length nipple again
and again
dragging at that whimpering duck that
has
no further yields no further yields
conan
[Laughter]
did you just refer to my breast as a
doug
i mean i think no one's done that since
t.s eliot that was
my hat my my virtual hat is off to you
my presumably noodle-like
gray doug that's fantastic
the english people have not held an
american in such high regard since t.s
eliot
came to this country and right near to
where i live right now as a matter of
fact to write some of his
greatest poetry yeah i think i think
conan
look this is what i truly believe and
the fact is is that um in it i'm
like the original intention was to go on
a sort of yes perhaps potentially
psychedelic journey certainly to me
shaman neurologists and geniuses of
every description in order to discover
what is it
what is it that's going to fulfill us
now now that we
the we know that the material world
cannot quench us now that we know
technology is not going to
provide us the answer particularly
technology in the hands of the same
people that have deployed the mindset
that has led us to the precipice where
we now find ourselves
therefore an investigation into the
sacred the re-sacrificing of the
everyday
make our relationship with one another
sacred make our communities sacred
make even our haircuts and now crystal
wands sacred this is surely the answer
so
i couldn't do that though because
obviously you know the pandemic if i got
locked up travel got banned
so i sort of just simply had to go on a
journey of reflection and introspection
but they were so they were still
i was able to discover the sacred
through this through the death of
friends through the death of my
dear beloved recently reincarnated in
kitten form so i don't know i mean there
is a reincarnation because it's another
life but i'll show you the evidence i
mean you may think i sound mad but i can
show you the kitten
as i often find myself saying in court
[Laughter]
do you are you saying that you lost
someone and that you believe they've
been reincarnated as a kitten
it's not as crazy as it sounds because
it was a cat in the first place
oh and in fact i can show you this well
wait yes
a cat coming back as another cat what's
that all about
it's not game show it's not like you're
trying to live as me it's not like
doctor do little carousel oh i was a cat
now i'm a dog now i'm a horse now i'm a
lizard
now i'm a boy child with a twinkle in
the eye now i'm a wandering minstrel
the idea is just that we're on some
limitless wheel
of the non-material world is realizing
itself through material there are
subtler frequencies making himself
manifest through mata and if that's a
problem for you
conan i will simply provide the kitten
and put this matter to bed
once and for all okay let's see this
amazing creature
that died as a cat and came back
as another cat that that
we may live that we may live oh my god
you know when you're going on easter as
well
you're descending into your own mind
right now you're lost ladies
ages we must venture into the underworld
the retrieve the boom how else are we to
retrieve the moon without
this is one so let's put this argument
about reincarnation which is a sacred
belief to the hindus let's face it and
uh and
if you don't believe that that's a
serious matter talk to hank azaria
a depiction by noel fielding the great
british comedian
of my cat morrissey here is a further
depiction by another artist he was much
beloved
artists couldn't they couldn't get
enough of him they were always
depicting him this is by david lynch and
it's a
it's a drawing of what he says limitless
consciousness looks like and if you
if you can if you can follow that you
should probably try watching one of his
films
now here is what beneath this humble
blanket
is the answer to life's great mysteries
conan when i draw back the veil
prepare to be dazzled because this
ordinary bengal cat oh see now you see
how look at that that's gorgeous really
beautiful
oh how many oh they're beautiful are
they so lovely and look at her she
doesn't know
she doesn't know she's on tps and there
could be a dozen people watching this
right now
well that's quite optimistic it doesn't
shook them by now russell
uh maybe maybe on the youtube
if we don't know about you we don't
worry about those things those are
material concerns that i don't worry
about
meaningless equals vanity who cares
this is the moment it doesn't matter if
people watch it or not it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter all our all our
graves go unattended
you know that's what i say we uh weeds
grow over our tombstones who cares
enjoy the next dust on the wind of
history conan
here we are trying to make how talk
shows work and our audible original
cell and for what this did christ on the
cross
did cat jesus come back on easter monday
by the way
just so that we could squander our
precious time here pursuing ratings
no i answered it um listen so which one
is
which one is the which one is the
reincarnated morrissey
well he's actually on the nipple now and
i'm reluctant to remove him because it
seems
cruel but i will do it because you know
this is otherwise the
bit doesn't have a natural conclusion so
you know i've still got a producer's
mind even though i only work very well
television the bit has to have a finish
uh that's one of the
sacred uh that's one of the sacred
truisms of the universe
it does you can't yeah if there's a
rifle oh sorry i felt him come off of
the nipple there that was um i
felt wrong that's morrissey behold cat
jesus he has risen
and i'm not making a mockery of
christianity there by the way just you
know you saw the pictures by noel
fielding
you saw the drawings by lynch you see
this cat you see that all the others
are bengal looking and here he is
where is in the gun go back go back it's
a shame we can't offer him your little
noodle nip to have a little suck on see
if he can't get the last bit of bay
watches
titty juice you've gone
you know this in our country about 50
years ago we had a saying
you've gone crackers man you've flipped
you've you've lost it you've gone mad
you've got you may i get excited
sometimes by you and by you encourage me
and this is always a problem
at school and as a heroin addict if
people encouraged me
i would take more heroin until the point
where i sometimes felt quite unwell
yeah well i'm glad those days are behind
you now i'm glad
you seem happy uh you seem comfortable
you seem centered and at peace um i've
loved i've loved seeing your home i'd
love to visit in person one day
when that's allowed yes i would love
that i would certainly have you here
you're a very
tall person with in a sense no need to
make themselves a follicular bonnet but
you've done that nonetheless
but you you would fit in our humble
cottage and we would very much love to
take care of you if we
could mr o'brien i mean we would offer
you our finest gruel
why did we suddenly go into a dickens
novel um
i don't know i was uncomfortable with
sincerity i know
i'm sure it's a feeling you must well
i'm gonna make sure i get the word out
revelation
connecting with the sacred in everyday
life is available now exclusively on
audible uh russell i say this with
sincerity
um i can't think of who i enjoy talking
with more
it's always pyrotechnic uh beautifully
strange uh and i
it's i i'm always in heaven when we're
babbling our foolishness and uh so thank
you if you made my day i really
appreciate it and i hope that i made
your night
because you're in england right now
that's right and yeah you're a valuable
person in my life and i hope i get to
see you when i'm next over there
and our door is always open to you not
literally that would be a security risk
but metaphorically consider it open
well russell brand thank you very very
much this was very nice and
i think now you should just slip off to
sleep you know i think you should close
your eyes
just just drift off to sleep i'm
beginning to think that these are my
last precious moments alive and this is
the vision that will present me as i
pass into the next life
goodbye
[Laughter]
go to the light russell go to the light
lights never look more attractive you
will be reincarnated as
russell brand
[Laughter]
yeah wow man crazy
how does that happen all right russell
thank you take care
lots of love conan take it easy bye